the left has really become the little
boy who has cried not seeing what do we
mean by that they have accused everyone
of being a Nazi for so long including
yours truly gearing up this was the
attack before Donald Trump right it was
set it was racism with Barack Obama was
sexism with Hillary Clinton and when the
sexism thing wasn't working enough uh
full-blown Nazi so they've accused their
opposition of being Nazis for so long
that now when you have someone who is an
actual white supremacist who rammed him
to people with his car killing one it
falls on deaf ears Owen Owen Benjamin
her friend said yeah but you now have to
use the same word for dave rubin that
you use for this guy who ran someone
over with a car ben shapiro me Milo Ted
Cruz and the guy in the Dodge Challenger
have all been lumped in the same because
you've used the word Nazi repeatedly
there's no way to escalate it and so the
issue here is we've become so
desensitized that this week people right
away we're skeptical had to fact-check
it and that's where both sides are
culpable okay both sides have had their
violent outbreaks obviously but where
the left is truly capable here is of
creating a culture of painting all
political opposition as Nazis to the
point where no one believes them they
are truly the little boy who cried Nazi
ok kids so today Timmy the bear will be
teaching us about the little bear who
cried Nazi does anyone know what a Nazi
is that's right they're socialists there
once was a bear who worked in news and
to silence any voices of dissent he took
a great breath and shouted out Nazi Nazi
those right-wing protesters are Nazis
and the villagers came running to try
and scare the Nazis away but when they
arrived they saw that there were no
Nazis those are but tea partiers
protesting higher taxes the villagers
said Timmy you mustn't cry Nazi when
there is no Nazi yes that's right he
lied
Timmy lied but the bear couldn't help
himself he saw voices of political
opposition once more and so he broadcast
loudly
see not see there are Nazis as the
villagers came running and looks before
them they sternly responded that is no
Nazi that is dave rubin who is an open
homosexual and a jew save you're
frightened song for when there is truly
a nazi do not cry nazi when there is no
Nazi thats Timmy learns LGBTQA IP - well
we'll talk about that next week don't
disrupt later that year Timmy saw real
Nazis they were large angry and scary
carrying swastika signs and walgreens
tiki torches Nazis Nazis Timmy yelled
out but the villagers thinking that
Timmy was trying to fool them once more
did not come later at sunset the
villagers wondered why Timmy had not
returned and so they set out to search
for him only to find out that Timmy had
been run over by a Dodge Challenger
Timmy proclaimed I cried out Nazi Nazi
why did you not come the villagers
responded but Timmy you called ben
shapiro and dave rubin nazis so you see
Timmy you can go [ __ ] yourself because
children the moral to this story is
nobody believes a liar even when they're
telling the truth and so goes the story
of the little bear who cried Nazi if you
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if you're
not aware of it now there's no way
you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit com /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than $6 a month and you
get daily content no more clips plus
this hand edge mug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside